it's so weird after being on set since I
was little it's like you don't even
notice that anymore you're just getting
pulled every which way I don't know how
same time that I did so I play a guy
named will omsford also just this
responsibility that I felt that bringing
Eugene O'Neill's words to life they
don't even know it but they have guided
my career they've guided my life well
the way that this came about I was
actually I was I was doing uh the Iceman
Cometh on Broadway how long did it take
to perfect that I mean I had a year and
a half before I started shooting where I
didn't do anything else but obsessed
about it oh you know I think there's
there's habitual things when you do one
thing for two years yeah you create
habits I do want to address something
there's there's people out there who say
that ever since I played Elvis my voice
has changed I don't think I sound like
him still but I I guess I must because I
hear it a lot right now I'm in this room
full of my heroes you all remembered and
I will never forget thank you